you know what makes you interesting
um
you know sometimes we're uncomfortable
to tell our story it's like look it's
not that big of a deal it's my life
where you know we're just telling our
life story
um
here's what makes you very unique as an
artist and i don't know if the world
appreciates you as much as they do and
i'll unpack my opinion on how i view you
okay
um
so
for somebody to have
the amount of life you know acting is
what to to to draw from a certain place
you were at in your life to get into
that emotion or reacting you know
there's different kind of acting but a
person who's more well-rounded they can
go and explain a scene better because
they can go there right so
background bad republican economist
conservative
then he loses debt divorce you can draw
from what it is to be a father
republican conservative then you
experience a kid divorced 16 years old
heartbroken
what it is to have that take place mom
french so you learn the history of
french because mom's gonna pass that
down to you then you go
military so you have a little bit of
that experience from the military you go
to see exactly what's going on in
vietnam i mean you draw from that for a
movie which leads later on to platoon
which i don't know how many times i
watch platoon when i was in the army
then you're talking about yale to be
around people like bush who come from
families of strong lineage and they get
to go there so you see what parties they
can participate in and you can't and how
that privileged life is like than being
a teacher your compassion for the africa
african-american black community and
then coming i mean the
the amount of things you can draw from
and you tell the story we feel it
meaning we be in the audience
we see your final product we don't
we see what you're putting together so
it's it's impressive and one of the
things that i appreciate about your work
is the fact that look
today we had a doctor here on and we're
having a conversation with them and and
i remember years ago when i got enamored
by jfk what happened with them all of a
sudden i'm like i gotta interview i
watch your documentary jfk and obviously
i've seen a movie i've seen a lot of
this stuff but last time i'm watching a
documentary
and abraham bolden i remember when we
interviewed him five years ago or clint
hill or
rfk or
you know cyril wecht cyril and i had a
phenomenal interview together because i
want to know that story
but you also it this is what it comes
across to me i think young filmmakers
who are not afraid who have audacity and
they have the guts to do
what an artist ought to do and and we
ought to let this person do what they're
doing is
it seems like you're the kind of guy
that if you are looking at castro and
nobody's saying stuff about castro like
look i don't know what you think you
hate them you love them you can't stand
them you could care less about them
i wanted to learn that's what i wanted i
don't want to judge i want to learn okay
you this putin guy is a horrible person
great okay let's say you're right people
from russia some of them love them some
of them hate them i don't know you know
what hey can we do an interview i want
to learn right hey this ukraine thing
everything i hear about with ukraine you
know
love them hate them you know the battle
of victors and all this other stuff i
don't know i want to learn i think the
courage you have
to go touch some of the subjects that
the rest of the world is like well
fox news said this they must be right
siena said this they must be right msnbc
said this they must be right new york
post said that they must be a new york
times said they must be right you're
like
yeah i don't know if i believe anyone i
kind of want to find out for myself that
takes a lot of courage to do what you
you what you've done
that's what's impressive i think our
stories are similar because what you
told me is you came from a very
from syria iran born and raised in but
my dad was in syria my mother was
armenian
so you've been you've been you're the
you're the ultimate too you're a refugee
from those situations and you you're in
this country which is a big open
freeway in many ways and a
marketplace of ideas but you're open and
you want to see you want to learn that
was what happened to me and i and i'm
still on that journey and i'm 75 years
old i'm still can't i'd love to know
more i'd like to
so many people i'd like to meet but it's
you know the the
rigidity and the orthodoxy is what
always
close you down they always limit you
constantly all my life
uh you know my father at first you know
he's certainly didn't approve of my my
thoughts about
the war and this and
and certainly i started to question
economics you know he was a big franklin
roosevelt he was not he was he was there
in the 1930s he was there in the
depression he despised roosevelt and i
had that most of my childhood but as i
got into american history more and more
and really studied it i went back
not in school years later with my
project untold history of the united
states it's a 12-part history i think
it's i'm very proud of it
it took five years to put that together
with peter kuznick a historian who
taught me
had me read the right books and think
about american history in a completely
different way than i thought of it
before and that's the result of that and
among and roosevelt is very much a
pillar in that movie and so is john
kennedy
it becomes more and more apparent the
more you read about mr kennedy that he
was truly in that same tradition of
roosevelt being open-minded to other
people very much as an irishman
anti-colonial
very much so oh had a much more deeper
relationship with africa
with indonesia with south america and
with nasa in egypt than we know nasser
was heartbroken when yeah but there was
a he was working very
effectively to re-establish american
relations with these countries in
sukarno and indonesia and he was
changing the policy in vietnam
unfortunately he didn't live long enough
to to get it done
because lyndon johnson who was supposed
to be his transition was went in a
complete u-turn in a different direction
immediately which american historians do
not admit
so here again this is an interesting
we've come across orthodoxy in history
too
and in our thinking and in our media
and that's always been my problem coming
up against that and being criticized for
that
for challenging those views is is that
because the natural like you know how we
grow up like the one person you never
question as your father that
if you eventually were like i don't know
if my dad's right and i'm gonna go
figure it out for myself like that is
still with you at 75 where today father
maybe the president or the government or
the media or whatever you like
yeah there's got to be something more to
it is that kind of your mindset there's
got to be something more to it than what
i'm hearing
well my mother has come plays a huge
role here because my mother was a rebel
we haven't talked much about her she was
she was a rebel part of the reason the
divorce was what it was is that she
rebelled against the system she didn't
want to live inside that
box where the man has adult commits
adultery all the time and the woman
doesn't so she broke her she made her
own rules up and she had fun she was
quite a liver uh and she was quite
many friends she was loved by so many
people i can't tell you and i think
that's a great quality to have opposites
as parents wow uh
not to say my father wasn't funny he was
also very funny but it it wasn't like
they were
she had a different spirit and rebelled
all the time she had lived through the
occupation nazi occupation
in paris in world war ii so she was uh
she she really appreciated
the freedom uh
that after a war
and uh
a very loving person
so she's in my she's in my heart
she's always there
but i take from both of them both
parents are very strong later on did you
ever kind of think and say you know
i used to uh not agree with my dad on
these two things you know
now that i'm 52 years old this one part
that i disagree with my dad i agree with
him he was right here and he was right
here and
he was wrong there and she was wrong
there and she was right did that happen
sure oh yeah was there anything specific
people that's what life is like my my my
mother because of my father became
a republican she supported you know
reagan and
all that but she didn't really it was
all
you know inside that she was a free
spirit got it and totally uh
and frankly uh john kennedy my father
was skeptical about him didn't he
preferred nixon
and uh me too at that point it took me a
long you have to learn for yourself
that's what the whole point of life is
it's your it's your it's your path to
learn if you don't change if you're
still the same person you were when you
were young
well you might like it but
it doesn't show that you have tried
other states of being
pat what's the one thing you always say
about first you love your parents then
you begin to disagree with them and then
eventually you start to humanize them
what do you always idolize demonize
human eyes yeah that's the three phases
you go through parenting yeah that's
pretty well said idolize uh demonize
humanize so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you're not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]